it's 6:30 in the morning father saju
George is preparing to say Mass
his parish is in a small village south
of Kolkata father Sanju has been working
in this economically depressed region
for nearly 30 years
father Sanju is a Jesuit he has a
doctorate in theology and was ordained
to Catholic priest in 2001 this is where
he set up a cultural center dancing his
father saw Joe's passion a way of
expressing his faith for him dancing is
a form of Prayer I take the technique
that I have learned from Indian
classical dance in music and I used the
spiritual or the philosophical content
of the Bible and I make a new
choreography father you can do like this
a father a person seated father Sanju
performs and teaches his prayer dance
all over the world
recently he was invited to Germany
priest makes travel arrangements on his
cell phone the invitation to Germany was
from Munich it's not just an opportunity
to get to know Germany the German
Catholic Church's International
missionary organization missio is
celebrating its 175th anniversary father
saju has been asked to present his
biblical choreography to invited guests
including cardinal ty not Marx missio
sponsors education and training of
church personnel in Africa Oceania and
Asia in 2003 it awarded father Sancho a
scholarship it offers the young people a
measure of security they can pursue
their studies or projects for two or
three years without having to worry
about earning a living at the same time
and we have the satisfaction of training
men and women in theology and philosophy
to be ambassadors of their local church
the coach after arrival in local and
eosin
father saju views himself as an
ambassador of Indian culture and of his
vocation in life to spread the Christian
faith he uses classical Indian dance to
tell the story of Jesus Christ
mazi time can steer his dance is very
expressive he explained that it was
about the suffering death and
resurrection of Christ so you have these
images in your head it's a form of
exploring the faith in a different way
we don't express our faith like that so
it really grabs our attention and as we
watch we see that a great deal can be
expressed in dance I think that the
audience here really felt that using
hand gestures called mudras father saju
teaches the audience how to tell Bible
stories
it was gold experience is wonderful
especially to do some dance movements
with the people and the very positive
idea while trying to do it and it was
nice dancing to them Hamburg Germany the
Jesuit is here to visit to dance
teachers Katia Shivani and Anna gova
both are passionate about Indian dance
and have studied it professionally they
Revere the great exponents of the
classical tradition
when they saw a video of father Assad
you on the internet they decided to
invite him to Hamburg
yeah but in tongues we're very impressed
by what he said about dance art about
the spirituality in it and what it means
for him it was Universal and not at all
dogmatic although he's a Catholic priest
when usually thinks of priests as being
less broad-minded densify guys decent
the two dance teachers organized a
beginners course with father saju Jorge
here he demonstrates the first steps of
the Bharata Natyam a Hindu dance that
originated in the temples of Tamil Nadu
the Jesuit expresses his Christian faith
in these graceful sculpture like poses
doctrine you can see he is quite
charismatic I thought it interesting
that he combines various religions and
wants to combine various cultural
backgrounds I think that comes across
very well in the workshop the mental
discipline the discipline in thought and
movement no movement is spontaneous it's
all very how should I put it disciplined
Bharata Natyam is a solo dance with two
aspects graceful feminine lines and
masculine strength
it's danced by both men and women
okay that's it
while in Hamburg the indian jesuit is
invited to perform in a Lutheran Church
costumes and makeup are an integral part
of the Indian dance tradition the bindi
a red dot on the forehead provides the
final touch it's placed at the center of
the forehead close to the eyebrows
putting this mark on the forehead it is
it is a kind of beautifying oneself and
also it's it's a sign of in Indian
culture red mark is a sign of purity of
mind and body and and artistically this
also looks a very very attractive point
today father saju is presenting his holy
spirit choreography a highly unusual
performance in this Lutheran Church the
Protestant spectators are fascinated by
this new approach to their faith
in a city like Hamburg we experience a
variety of cultures every day and I
personally think it's important that we
try to understand each other to talk to
each other
inter-religious dialogue is very
important to me not just to talk about
each other but to learn from each other
to hear how other people express
themselves and what they feel then I see
perhaps what unites us and also notice
the differences that it's important to
respect each other as we are back in
India this is where father Sancho is
making his dream a reality
building up the cultural center he calls
collodion which is Hindi for art of art
with his reputation as a teacher he's
already attracting dancers from all over
the country
the profit from these dance courses and
performances is all invested in his
ambitious project this is a new building
that we built recently this is a
multipurpose building mostly for
conducting dance theater music workshops
or seminars so now we are conducting a
workshop a seminar on Indian classical
dance that is a Bharatanatyam
running the dance center requires a lot
of time and energy and organizing travel
arrangements for the dance groups also
takes a lot of effort the students want
expert teachers and certificates in
future father Saji would like to
cooperate with a university but for that
more guest housing would be needed his
former mentor thinks the 49 year old
demands too much of himself I don't know
how much the time he gets with such
responsibility of building up a life an
institution which is his passion which
is his doing work I think what he needs
is somebody will help him all through
very confident a confident you know move
in with whom he can share the work so
that he has enough time for his dance
also on his trips abroad father Sanju
makes lots of useful contacts his fellow
Jesuits in Switzerland for instance
bought him this nine seater Jeep
the keys are handed over in Kolkata and
in good Catholic tradition the drivers
and the vehicle are blessed with holy
water we have a little more easier and
smooth travel to the city and also for
the work in two different places that we
take our groups whether they travel for
business of nature that them always find
Christ to the companions of the journey
who lives and reigns forever and ever
on its maiden voyage through the narrow
streets the bright red Jeep sails over
the potholes there's a second blessing
awaiting it in the village morning
prayer at the cultural center the next
day Julian Lutz is from Switzerland and
working as a volunteer at a dance center
he says he's attracted by the way
spirituality is lived in India it's a
completely different world and I see a
lot more tolerance here than I ever
imagined people of all religions are
welcome at father Sanju's cultural
center that is evident in the chapel
he's building it will be dedicated to
Mary the mother of Jesus for Hindus
mother mother cult or mother with child
is very attractive mother figure so
Hindus also come and pray they don't
think that its mother
Mary it's the Christians goddess and
even for Muslims mother Mary is part of
the qur'anic no experience
father saju turns to his fellow Jesuits
in Kolkata for support he's encouraged
by their enthusiasm for the direction in
which he plans to develop his center
he's also making this as a forum for
dialogue a dialogue between cultures
between religions dialogue between
people he's able to bring no European
brother into his Center listen that you
say quite you know attuned with the
today's globalized world the Jesuit
priest is also attuned to the needs of
the poor villagers these isolated
communities are only accessible via
narrow mud tracks there's heavy rainfall
in these parts and the roads are often
impassable over that mark they put
bricks now they slowly start using
concrete so therefore a slow gradual
development of the passage system
most of the villagers here are done it
traditionally regarded as untouchable in
the Indian caste system many of them
have no educational opportunities
the Jesuits help them as much as they
can we not only do the spiritual help
you know the spiritual nourishment but
also we give educational help if we have
a school here more than 150 years old
the poor people here not only lack
education often they don't even have
adequate housing father's a Jew buys
them basic building materials not enough
to meet all their needs but at least to
make a start so we cannot do a finished
furnished house so it's only the the the
basic support they need so they get a
hope then it they need a courage to
start off now that's what most people
need later slowly slowly they add their
own they also work and they somehow you
know build
finish you may take say two years three
years five years that doesn't matter but
they can live they have a roof over
their head
the priest is only able to help a few
families in this way his funds are very
limited
from time to time father Sanju was also
able to provide work for the villagers
they cook in a kitchen or work in the
gardens there's very high unemployment
in this region inevitably his
flourishing cultural project in the
middle of this destitute part of West
Bengal also provokes resentment I have
sometimes little problems will be with
the local local clubs for example I that
is not anything connected with the
religion that is they want some money so
they block sometimes my work here they
simply want you know to have a control
over what we do here
the brand-new vehicle also gives rise to
envy lots of people here have to make do
with a bicycle fighting their way
through the traffic
father sanju already has a motorcycle
license and is familiar with the
problems
learning to drive a car presents new
challenges to drive the car in Calcutta
it is very difficult you have to be
there to be really expert driver to do a
good job in Calcutta because a very kind
the streets are congested and now the
vehicles are increasing day by day and
the all kinds of vehicles are on the
road and there are no you know different
lanes for for recycles or bicycles and
tricycles
after his driving lesson father saju has
to rush off this evening is the opening
of his dance festival in Kolkata he
hopes it will raise awareness of his
cultural center Kolkata has four and a
half million residents and is known as
India's cultural capital Christian
Catholic newspaper about the program
jesuit center to organize dance festival
and seminar with our photograph
fatherís Hodja buys candles to welcome
the guests of honor
the festival is taking place at st.
Xavier's College a Jesuit school that
has served Calcutta for more than 150
years after some delay the lighting
technicians arrived they were held up in
one of the city's legendary
traffic jams the guests will be arriving
in just a few hours
there's no charge to attend father saju
is expecting an audience of about 500 a
number of them are important dance
teachers gurus especially for classical
Indian dance and music and arts the the
teacher-student relationship is very
important it's it's that we call it a
guru coolest system or guru shishya
system so we are like their children
they are like our parents they are like
our preceptors or we emulate them no
they are the people who we look up to
for the learning of
arts as well as for our life some of
them are they are our philosophers and
guides the dancers know what's at stake
it's the future of father saju Center
just 20 kilometers from here this
evening they're performing for
Calcutta's cultural elite
from the dressing-room father saju gives
final instructions but before the show
starts the volunteer from Switzerland
also has to dress for the occasion
then the audience starts to arrive the
visiting dance teachers and gurus open
the festival brother sajju and various
dance groups present their work
the highlight of the evening is a
performance by father seduced own
teacher professor Chandra Sekhar a
highly respected guru who is now 80
years old the evening is a triumph for
father saju and his dance center it took
place with the grace of God as we wanted
to take place and I feel so peaceful and
so happy and excited within souvenirs
snapshots of this important evening the
next day the dancers meet for lunch at
father Sanju's but the priest himself
doesn't have any time he's already
planning his next tour he needs to
promote his Khalid ayah centre abroad to
raise money for its development it needs
many more people many more generous
hearts to make this heart you know heart
of art really vibrate with the art
father saju is a tireless dancer and
priest in ten years he says his Center
will be part of a university and he
himself will never stop dancing the
Bible